hi my name is Eric and my sis is titled
crystal breaking the idea for this
thesis comes from my interest in how
people artists especially break or
otherwise misused systems for the
purposes of my thesis like it's that are
848 to be an unintentional around its
unexpected behavior from a system from
the perspective of the fund invested
party important thing to take away their
from that are that its perspective oh
it's based on a person's perfect
interpretation of it and it's also not
really the negation of effect it can be
an unexpected behavior purposes of my
thesis so in this existence out
instances of this breakdown can actually
speak to or reveal many aspects of
systems beyond the merely technical or
formal aspects pictured here are places
from juvie org in the background screw
Mario clouds on the left and then an
excerpt from the Friends day video by
arigato on the right I wanted to come up
with a framework to better pack up our
artists like these and other people in
digital systems can't break those in
those systems how those instances of
creating can be deployed as critical
analysis and side to call the framework
for breaking to emphasize to the
critical analysis aspect through
analysis of the vehicle algorithm
studies literature and feminist science
studies I further developed freaking
methods of critical breaking analysis
auditing systems negotiating
relationships
revealing the context of systems we have
run through each of them quickly to
explain what I mean by them auditing
systems by this I mean discovering how
system works under certain criteria and
why this is especially cruder than the
system itself is biased against a part
of life group for example discovering
embedded biases and systems as a problem
in studying digital systems digital
systems for a long time that may have
many attempts been made to quantify our
taxonomy sit nice involving Freeman's
1996 biasing and feeder systems is a
good place to look once in the
beginnings of that what information
about how a system is built is made
public and Alyssa left little recourse
with the developed read that it's oddly
system these methods however can be slow
and costly reverse engineering it is an
example of that and can frequently be
made obsolete by updates to the system
especially relevant in network and
Internet cases I suggest for bringing as
a supplement to these things and precise
a short form with audits done drinking
oh I'm a response in the moment but do
not hold over the totality of assistant
or in the long term you go to the
relationship of systems is my second
angle and the most grim outlook on human
system relationships is most likely to
loses control society hypothesis which
basically states that all human actions
will be suddenly controlled and shaped
by the systems we use all while
presenting an illusory idea of
meaningful choice and agency amor
istic outlook comes from Alex Galloway
tactical media yeah is that their
tactical media interventions systems can
be transformed to suit the needs of
their users as opposed to the needs of
their careers in question to answer here
for me is how much of our relationship
with systems is actually valuable and
shiftable to our own needs and have been
locate to perform those shifts if they
exist after the optimist I situate
critical breaking as a framework that
can that can through analysis of where
the how systems break help isolate
highlight those places and show us
passed to eventually enacting those
ships thirdly revealing the context of
systems in order to actually perform the
breaking of a system this is somebody's
actually exists materially this
materiality gives it an embedding in the
world the finest so this final broad
category or analysis that's possible
critical breaking it's highlighting and
highlighting revealing and highlighting
aspects of the context in which the
system exists for example asking for
whom a system is broken gets into a web
of perspective and expectation that
reveals important information that is
almost necessarily located outside of
the system itself and it's like these
get critical breaking the analysis to
the reach to be connected to the wider
world while still remaining situated in
focus on itself so
to build out the concept of critical
breaking the big part of my thesis is
composed of three case studies across
three four chapters in each I examine a
different kind of breaking the digital
systems in the fair with my central or
concept of critical breaking I sure what
parts these practices that are useful or
resident breaking that should be
incorporated into a critical breaking
framework or practice and which aspects
are limitations that you can critique
your kid falls to avoid my through case
these are running software testing and
activism each of these represent
different kind of breaking in different
contexts you're running allows for a
discussion of breaking games an
interesting area to both to be mostly
closed nature game systems at least
older games that are not regularly
updated and one change and also games
have effective and aesthetic values
incorporated into them unlike many
digital systems games try to tell a
story and have art direction and those
influence the ways in which they're
broken software testing amount of our
discussion of corporate breaking it's
breaking is done for business reasons
and that has concrete applications and
the methods and frameworks that they use
notably things like efficiency and
accountability have changed software
testing over its history and very
compelling wigs all breaking is at least
a little bit political activism is very
political and how I was an exploration
of our breaking techniques and tools
hold up when I have a revolutionary or
Liberatore or decentralized ideological
mandate the coherence of politics the
cross Brady tools and in breaking
practice is the main focus of that
chapter due to their difference I were
provided in different methodology for
investigating each of them and I will
describe that in their relative seconds
of this presentation there was a liquor
view
boring and settle for your welcome I got
your diner so my first case study is be
writing to be running for the roses are
you do not know is a video game practice
where a player tips were cheap some
objective in that video game as quickly
as possible usually this involves using
glitches or exploits in the game to save
time across the globe there are
communities to speed writer from
collaborating to find these kinds of
glitches complete professes times and
set up structured marathons reruns are
co-pays for an audience due to its
relative newness there is some that not
very much literature on speedrunning as
such the most productive investigative
methods for me in this case they were
air user speedrunners on-site interviews
and pops on on-site observation and
textual analysis recorded speed runs in
which there are a lot most interviews I
conducted more online though some are
also in person at sgdq one of my
research sites sgq or summer games done
quick is one of the two largest cherries
running marathons in the United States
takes place in Minneapolis and draw
speed runners from all over the world my
secondary site was a mathon 3a just for
fun ironic speedrunning marathon where
all the speedruns were deliberately bad
or silly or compromised or just
straight-up unwatchable in some way i
did also get some deep dives into a
specific speedrunning techniques
researching how and why they work in the
various games in which to take place in
addition to all of this stuff i also
include a limited discussion of game art
as an example of a different kind of
breaking and in games context and what
is it worse I discusses
murrieta screech other fail so what did
I find out what are my conclusions they
might chapter or throw a lot of
different facets of speedrunning
including different ways to break games
and the philosophical and organizational
aspects of any communities and
importantly speedrunning and counter
play my chapter and prepare speedrun
degree in computers idea counter play
which is basically the idea of playing
against a system in a politically
resistant way speedrunning fits
counterplay definitionally in the micro
sense individual breaks and ledges in
the game from the persistent way the
room is coated on a moment-to-moment
basis on the macro level spilling is
really just the ultimate fan activity
great date my way of explaining this to
be hunting is very expect full of and
limited by broader gang structure like
we're a game begins an end and Victor
uses of the game Superman has a very
close engagement became systems that
allows it to make very powerful impacts
on the game systems they speedrun which
i think is an important model for strong
critical breaking but their ultimate
hang up inside of game design precludes
them from making critical statements
about games more broadly than that I
love at this high level analysis not
something as speedrunners aspire to in
their practice I shouldn't say but there
the structure of their practice their
practice also makes it impossible for
them to do that and that's important too
in case of doing critical breaking work
this should tell us that the goal those
are indicators that esta for critical
reading should be extra systemic if
possible to avoid to recapture by the
system and stunting of analytic results
as a result of that game art is an
example of how this is possible as aims
of game originally meant to kick Spears
by a human audience and not meant to be
analyzed by the game system itself and
therefore avoiding kind of that
recapture that's figuring goes through
so my second case study was software
testing software testing is the practice
of testing programs were bugs and errors
usually done in a corporate context very
common is a silo testing known as
destructive testing which are they
temporary times to break the software in
order to retro actively prove that there
was a bug at a laptop to break it
destructive testing is also done in
physical testing situation the car crash
test picture there but there are many
many other kinds of testing that food in
both physical test again software
testing situations which I do
incorporate some degree in my chapter
the main focus is on the destructive
testing and the implications of it
so my methods for this chapter were
primarily analysis of various text
related to software testing materials
including historical academic writing on
testing contemporary academic writing on
testing consumer textbooks independent
textbooks and qualifications board
materials which no supper test I spoke
to ever has ever cared about and serves
as an interesting artifacts on the web
about suppertime I also have the tech
work this is a protester at one point in
my life and while I deficit to be an
ethnographic study by any means it does
color how I interpret my results in is
important fact to note so as an
inflection point in this chapter I also
use an Alison parish talk to include a
discussion of Twitter BOTS as a
different kind of creative breaking that
still happens inside the corporate
context and use that as a comparison
point to summer testing so my results
for this chapter I had to kind of key
findings one of them was that was just
tracing the ongoing formalization of
software testing for being a practice
that was just and I felt out and based
on gut instinct and intuition to a
highly texana mais de quantified field
that is also gradually being automated
most textbooks in consumer facing
material related some protesting
advocate I kind of like felt out method
of software testing but corporate
ownership of testing results in the area
pace of capitalism kind of lock testers
into more and more highly efficient and
formalized methods it's worth
considering from critical breaking
standpoint both these oral and informal
aspects intuition and gut checks are
good models for critical breaking
practices
very interesting and it's also we're
looking at their taxonomy and
quantification possibly for models for
disseminating and sharing critical
breaking results finding the balance
between these two I think is a really
necessary part of building a critic
breaking so I'm protestor software
testing is also really useful the case
that issue the importance of voting once
owned results it comes to critical
breaking software testers actually have
a very limited analytic range due to
their corporate restrictions testers can
only speak to problems in the software
that that company that employs them
would consider problems and actually to
reject their own personal opinions and
what might be wrong with the piece of
software some protesters fall to what
McKenzie work with described as in
hacker manifesto as victims of the
pectoralis classes they are unable to
act on the results of their own work
instead haven't manipulated by people
higher up our hierarchy in order to
actually tailor critical breaking
analysis to specific guys or ideology I
think is a very important part of what
I'm trying to present here this would be
unacceptable and should be avoided
final case study what's hacktivism the
breaking of systems were explicitly
political or ideological goals activism
usually done with really dubiously legal
methods and is tied up and they meet
those and legacy of hackers because
activism is such a broad area containing
so many different forms of methods I
thought it was no scruton to focus on
just a few case studies inside of this
case study and built directly on
previous work as such my main method for
this chapter builds on Molly's honors
work in the coming storm of the heat ah
seng tools up limit and the LOI c/d dose
is Stanford distributed denial of
service which basically means refreshing
a web page so many times that the server
gets overloaded and the web page gets
taken down in the coming storm solder
analyzes the UI user fixing the
functionality of these tools and my
chapter instead focuses on how these
tools are coded in the back end after to
revision I have my I'm a few more tools
incorporate into this chapter that are
related to these two but first at this
point it's just these three there are
two main takeaways for me whose gender
the first is that in order to develop a
break them tool in the digital system
certain media logical compromises have
to be made there are not that many
different ways to produce output in
traditional commercial computing
situations and almost all of them are
caught up in corporate or proprietary
schemes for instance the notorious
packing activism group Anonymous is the
LOI see which is code in a c-sharp a
language opened by Microsoft and does
comprehensive and professional error and
race condition handling in the tool I I
won't go into what those things
necessarily mean but it's reads very
their source code despite like the
outward tunnel reverence of the tool
which is
a lot of memes and stuff the way the
tools coded is actually extremely
professional the result of this should
not be to reject all possibility of
usual breaking for being compromised by
corporate programming paradigms but to
be aware of and bored with the ways that
these compromises are being made or the
tools that we use the other main take
where it could be a distractor was that
britain does not need to be convoluted
like expiry reading software testing off
comes in order to be effective he
tossing is pretty simple in concept and
implementation is only slightly more
complex but it's all as important
political effects and opens up really
interesting analytic angles this is
important tab for helping to scope and
plan breaking activities it's worth
considering what the core of a break is
achieved and focus on achieving those
small goals instead of building complex
and frameworks to connect so looking
forward include that slide of
mathematics is a really dramatic way of
presenting the equation for a circle
looking forward there are a number of
places i can see taking this research
one is just collecting more examples of
different ways to break digital systems
or different kinds of different get
breaking practices in typical context i
think would be really rude to think
about ways to collect these kinds of
insights and ways to present them maybe
bar software testing bug reports as a
model for that another correction would
be with these kind of physical systems
something i consider really early on for
this thesis building ultimately rejected
for scope and concerns
climbing streamlining of topic there are
many kinds of interesting about digital
systems that would with which to apply
the same kind of critical reading and
thinking my minor things like
bureaucratic red tape Maddox they spoke
about and general social norms and
behaviors that can loosely be considered
assistant and glued Harold well convert
studies and at the methodology there
because of his breaching experiment to
think are a lot of an interesting way of
thinking about this idea many of these
babies have connection Jewish nation
critical breaking as I believe there's a
lot of technique and set to be gained
across the arbitrary digital divide and
I set up for this thesis clearly I think
there's a lot more work that I could be
done with critical breaking that you
believe that this thesis is a good first
step that was great I was wondering if
you could repeat what you said about
speedrunning
if I mention quickly sort of like in
here and ability to critique ravings
more broadly yeah um could you tell me
more what you meant by that sure um back
to that slide buoyed by the time so i
think what i found the speedrunning is
that they are wetting themselves to game
design as their core principles of what
they do makes it impossible for them to
let me try to remember whatever into my
thesis so in order to make a politically
interesting statement about games you
need to be able to connect them to
things outside of the game itself like
the game itself as a closed system you
could say maybe interesting things about
the way it's coded or maybe the way like
your reward structure set up in a game
or something but to make it like more
politically just to need to have
reaching connections to something
outside of games and speedrunning this
kind of inside like commitment to
staying inside of the whole look like
what if game design is and with the game
the goals of game design art makes it
really difficult probably too strong but
it's really hard to get out of that not
just thinking that I wanted to
like the old facin success was grinning
is very fast inside of the game and that
makes that is kind of like a closed loop
that's hard to get out do you think that
the sort of leaned upon one gets a
little closer like does it mean it today
are those games were commentary on the
community sweet Mary oh yeah that's true
I mean the thought is like I really I
really don't want to give it too much
time because there's a lot of bad stuff
you helping the comments but yeah thank
you get kind of closer and it is a lot
of the ways that they do things were
satire but a lot of them were also just
yeah I think you can take me with on its
way to get out of that bubble butt
nemeth on is also like not considered
proper speed running by the community a
lot of cases and like they're explicitly
jokes and not analysis and things like
that patrol also problems but yeah I
think erect
we'll jump on in the next case which is
the software testing corporations that
constraints on what should be tested and
because Jeff's can't test and
so what's your proposition sort of step
outside that what is a who is the who's
the audience that will write yeah
appreciate this so so maybe kind of gave
related argument articles the way to
sort of confront this Genesis yeah I
mean I definitely am on board with that
and that's the thesis comes from a place
right thing or it is a good way to and
analyze that and I think what what that
was trying to get out with that
conclusion maybe didn't fully cover in
the talk was that I think it could be
really seductive or it is possibly a
compelling thing to try to make this
kind of thing into a career like or to
make it as part of like a to have some
kind of oversight or committee backing
you to do this with late make it
sustainable for you to do it as a glomp
over the long term and stuff like that
and I'm trying to problematize it by the
fact that you do have restrictions
coming never metals so this is coming
toward someone who wants to maybe try
breaking things in a critical analytical
a way but maybe doesn't have the money
to do it and then I want to dissuade
them trying to make it into like a more
formalized a according to get things out
the back
or something like what the problems with
that are through soccer testing and what
would you have anywhere where would that
leave the work really that booty present
that's a good question I think there are
spaces where that's becoming a more and
more of a thing but it is kind of like
maybe jumping the gun I'm shutting
things down but there are people there
are a lot of creative computing things
happening and they're bored we're
getting attention paid to live life with
your companies and I think that's kind
of where the rubber will be meeting the
road unlike where those things go and
there's going to be like Intel's Core of
creative computing people who bring
systems for Fitz people who do it on
their own and share the results is the
kind of other format if we were to just
start dumping this we're going to zoom
back and looking sort of existing
frameworks like after
general construction this up is this
about interpretive flexibility is this
about like we wonder sort of try to
understand where these practices what
these practices are they contesting a
kind of Mormon
our presence or they are they contested
at it in the sense we can read through
those commits an existing license or are
you proposing a new space I think you
read through existing those existing
lenses that's certainly like how I built
it a lot is based on interpretive
flexibility of things like that so no i
don't i would not be positioning this to
something that's like a new one of those
kinds of print works it is more of a way
of organizing a practice of breaking
things with some analytical frameworks
to better analyze
yeah so actually the question about the
speedrunning yadira form speedrunning
that relies on glitches to getting the
Patrick and you see that as operating
yeah that's that sport that's what I
want to get out with on a micro sense it
is not and I but at a macro sense it's
still obeying kind of broader game
design things but I'm not like a
point-to-point basis you're right that
they count and I've something I struggle
with a lot of ratings tracker was trying
to figure out where I fell on is that
like drooly Liberatore or is that still
inside of game design and kind of where
where I come down on that is it is still
offense within game design paradigms
even if there's like moment to moment
things worth bigs our vehicle exploited
it still comes back to that central loop
inside us
[Music]
alright
[Applause]